good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy friday you guys
so exciting hey claudia how are you
doing hello jacqueline happy hundred
percent day and happy friday friday
gotta get down on friday
it's a good day it's a big day it's
friday it's new music friday and that
means my anthem my
pop song that is taking the music
industry by storm
is out on spotify you can buy it on
itunes apple music it's called 100 by
claudia ashrae and we're wearing our 100
merch to celebrate the release of
another toasty life-changing anthem
we are so excited so nice to have
another song in the rotation
and it really is bop season i listened
to it last night before i went to bed
and then i woke up with it in my head
like it really gets stuck in your head
this song
that's amazing amazing to hear because
that was obviously the goal like a song
you just can't get away from and i agree
with you like as much as i love toast
like i needed a new bop especially for
tour so like if you're coming to shows
this week i'm going to be in dc and
philly at the end of next week like
learn the song we're gonna jam out to it
it's gonna become a big part of the show
so i'm just feeling very excited like
the reception has been really good at
first people were saying they really
like they were playing it and their
husbands were like is that miley cyrus
now i know husbands like
aren't like
the most accurate reporters but
it was more than one person that said
that and now people are saying it's
giving taylor swift during her message
in a bottle era so i just wanted to put
that out there because that's what
people are saying not even me i okay i
mean i get the miley vibe for sure i
just know i feel alone in this empty
house but i'm okay because we've got
power sweet and sour
and also i'm so glad you brought that up
a toast to us the wild ones i'm
incapable of having a song come out that
doesn't have the word toast in it and i
don't know about you but i'm dancing
with the boys and the girls
you know i think we should talk about
that
okay tell me about it
well i love it because i'm always
dancing with the boys and the girls the
gay boys and the girls
and when ben hur
that line
he was like what no when i just with the
boys and the girls when i heard the line
alone in this empty house i'm like
where's ben and now it's like because
with boys and girls where's ben oh my
god you're right
well whenever i like meet a new music
producer and i used a new producer this
time he was like tell me the vibe tell
me like yeses and nose i'm like well i'm
a married woman and a lot of songs are
like you know going to the clubs meeting
a man i'm like we can't have any of that
like this is a gno song because i'm just
i'm married and like i'm boring and so
we have to get creative with the lyrics
it's a song about friendship is what
you're saying
it's literally a song about friendship i
couldn't agree more okay i think the
world needs more songs about friendship
so check out 100 by claudia ashrae
streaming now on spotify anywhere you
listen to music or where you listen to
the toast you could probably
find her
and if you like are feeling so inspired
by the song go pick up some 100 merch
available at shopmorningtoast.com jackie
and i are both wearing the sweatshirt
there's matching pants that i'm going to
put on later to film a tick tock with my
new song because a major development
after yesterday's episode we reached out
to the choreographer via the podcast
we're like to whoever choreographed the
old tic-tock dance for toast if you're
still a toaster which you're probably
not hit us up
and of course she's still a toaster i
spoke to her last night she lives so
close to the spritz office that we
messengered her some spritz she wanted
to get it in the video
she literally choreographed it posted it
so fast it's up on her channel and she
posted a tutorial because the dance is
very complex and i'm gonna do i'm gonna
spend the rest of the day learning it
it's not gonna be easy for me
i wish you sent it to me i haven't seen
it yet oh she put it up this morning
i'll send you everything okay and i was
lucy jones i saw that she was found and
that she was getting to work but i
haven't seen the dance yet so i'm really
excited to see what people bring to the
dance i'm really nervous to do the dance
because like i'm just not good
at tick tock dancing and it actually
might be that i'm just not a good dancer
but that's a reality i'm not ready to
accept i think you're you're fine at
tick-tock dancing like just have fun
with it if you're having fun then what
about regular dancing what kind of
dancer do you think i am i think you're
a fine regular dancer too nothing to be
embarrassed about
but nothing to write home about either
um
no but i don't think that you write home
about it like i think you just hit the
dance floor you have a good time i think
it's all all about like if you look like
you're having a good time where you look
like you're uncomfortable do you know
what i mean that's true that's actually
incredibly true so no don't sweat it
you're a great dancer okay like that's
why i look i don't know if you notice
like extra beautiful today because i
will be spending the rest of the day
making tick tocks
that is a fun way for you to spend your
day i know there's nothing else you'd
rather be doing
well honestly what i'd rather be doing
is sitting down watching tick tocks
instead of making them but it's okay
i don't make tick tocks i just watch
them
literally
um well we've got a great show aside for
the fact that it's friday and there's
just going to be great energy coming out
of this episode because of the song but
also i have some things to talk about in
the tv recap because me and ben started
ted lasso okay how many episodes
four but i got like the gist of the show
you know you know what they're doing
there and i'm all caught up on sex in
the city and like i just have to tell
you what happened okay but i'll do it in
the tv recap because there's spoilers
and we'll just do it at the end of the
show fine by me sounds good to me i was
the hobby going the hobbies are going
good so i brought the piano up last
night but now i just need to find an
extension cord to plug it in where i
want to play it but my piano books
arrived last night so i haven't like
started practice yet practice starts
today
and i'm really excited to see
you know how it feels and if i'm any
good
and if it like occupies my time also
there's an element of muscle memory
there yeah but i also really needed the
hobbies for the weekends like during the
weekdays i'm actually really busy with
toe stuff and it's not until like
uh late afternoon that you know i'm
technically free and that's when i also
get so tired it's not when i'm looking
to play the piano so as we go into the
weekend it's going to be hobby filled i
will keep everyone posted on all of the
different things that i'm trying out
hopefully monday i'll have a hobby
update and i'll let you know what's
working and what's not working and did
all your [ __ ] arrive like you're paying
by the numbers no but i think it's
coming like today okay that's very
exciting you need like a a hobby room
because all these things take up a lot
of space yes well if you've noticed i
moved out from my bedroom into my living
room because i just thought the vibe was
a little bit prettier out here and i'm
hoping my connection is better because
yesterday my video was so [ __ ] and
like my mouth didn't match up with my
audio so i'm just trying new things and
that frees up my bedroom now there's a
piano in there like i'm not gonna
stream from the bedroom with the piano
in the background so the bedroom can
become the hobby room
my dining table can become my office and
i'm just moving things around
okay well whenever it is that you decide
you're ready to get on the
the track and remix 100 with the
keyboard
bruno and theo on the triangles you just
let me know okay it might be like an
acoustic version
i love that i love it love it love the
idea okay cool let's let everyone get
into this one first and then like in a
few fridays from now we'll release the
remix i love that
great stunning well we have a lot to
talk about today a lot of like news
stories
closing up for the weekend we're closing
up shop yesterday i watched the um
second part of jamie lynn on call her
daddy so we'll be talking about that
that was only tv technically that i
watched and we're gonna put this story
to bed because it's time
it's time i agree like
let sleeping dogs lie yeah
so i guess without further ado
are you ready
i'm ready without further ado it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
single drunk female samantha fink is a
person in progress and being a person is
hard single drunk female is the new
freeform original series now streaming
on hulu it's from the executive producer
of girls and the executive producer of
russian doll samantha used to get drunk
all the time but now she's getting clean
and that's going to get really messy
fresh out of rehab samantha is forced to
move back home and live with her mom who
she affectionately calls her smother she
works at a local grocery store she takes
naps in the cereal aisle and is going to
meetings she's taking sobriety one day
at a time but the days just keep on
coming with her former drinking buddy
and newly found friends of the program
by her side sam is trying to make the
most of her second chance a chance to
start over a chance to be a slightly
better person a chance at love when you
start when you start at rock bottom the
only way to go is up check out the new
dramedy that is sure to make you laugh
even if it's sometimes it's just to keep
you from crying freeform's single drunk
female is streaming now on hulu i caught
the first episode last night it was very
good i've been getting tick-tock ads for
it such a great show
yeah it was really it's really funny and
like um it's clever but it's like uh
nice and genuine too love that it has
heart
it's got heart
okay our first story speaking of heart
some unexpected celebrity relationship
news that i think we have no choice but
to ship
anna kendrick and bill hader have been
quietly dating for a year
i think we do have a choice oh you think
we have choices okay interesting a
source told people on thursday that the
two have been dating the insider said
anna has been dating bill quietly for
over a year they met years ago she's
hosted saturday live and they've done a
movie together but they got together
well after the movie the movie being
noel that disney plus christmas movie
the source said they are both very
private people and with the pandemic it
was easy to keep it quiet they're both
hysterical so they must
keep each other laughing all the time
she's really really happy yeah bill
hader is hilarious and hysterical for
sure yeah and you're so you're not a fan
of anna hendrick is what you're trying
to not say well i'm definitely not a fan
of anna kendrick but that doesn't mean i
don't want her to be happy and i do
think that relationships that get like
kept private for so long this is like a
definitely a real they've got a real
shot in hollywood which is tough these
days
i just don't see the match like for me
bill hader became a catch after the
movie train wreck behind you oh my god
for his no like he is the most eligible
man in the world handsome he's a doctor
yeah and i feel like not a lot of people
saw him like that until that movie yeah
i know i didn't i didn't really think
about him that much
i this story to me like if you told me
yesterday like bill hader and anna
kendrick are dating and i already and
you're telling me trying to convince me
that i already knew that like i would
believe you this is just like two people
really yeah like i just when i read it i
was like oh well that makes sense like
it almost just sounds so familiar like
yeah duh they should date
that's interesting i didn't have the
same experience i'm like what the [ __ ]
how random oh that's so funny i felt a
complete opposite like how
apt that's what i felt it was apt oh no
no anna kendrick is just one of those
girlies who like gets on my nerves i
think a lot of people feel that way um
but again that doesn't mean i don't want
her to be happy and find love so if this
is it that's wonderful i was just like
really surprised
remember when bill hader was dating
rachel bilson
see for me that was the feeling that you
got i was like oh my god like yeah
no for me they're two different worlds
some are roberts doctors
they are two different worlds for this
couple to me is like two people from the
same planet of two
no i'm not seeing it that way but i do
think that they have a lot of potential
and i love that they've been together
for so long and nobody knew it because
that means like
there's something real there oh yeah and
at this point like they've been dating
for a year they're extremely serious
it's not it's actually nice to hear
about it it's nice to hear about it one
year later and it's not like we have to
walk on eggshells like this is a real
relationship and we can either celebrate
and ship or you know opt out
yeah it's nice to not deal with like
they were spotted are they are they just
friends are they working on a business
project like no they're they might get
engaged soon like they've been together
for a year yeah i totally agree i wonder
why now like this source came forward
to tell people magazine i feel like that
was endorsed by the couple like i just
wonder
why they why now why this source
announcement yeah i really um when i
read the statement it really made it
seem like it was um
written by someone who works with anna
yeah no i feel like it was definitely
like endorsed by the couple they were
like we're ready to tell people just
like go and tell people magazine or
whatever um yeah
we also could have gotten like pictures
of them actually if we just got pictures
of them like kissing at a farmer's
market or something we would have
thought it was like their first date
yeah right we wouldn't have known that
it's been going on for months yeah so i
guess like they're just giving us all of
the information all at once and i do
appreciate that
it's funny that we're having so like two
totally different reactions i would love
to hear what other people think like
were you like oh yeah or were you like
what
oh my god i can't even imagine being
like what but let us know i can't even
imagine being like oh duh
no duh no i don't see it like that at
all that's so crazy because we always
have like the same yeah that's really
funny
are you ready for our next story which
is some really crazy news
before we do i feel like we should
mention that yesterday we recorded i
think one of our best podcast episodes
for the patreon channel yet
yes we did it was called toasters with a
secret and it's in the vein of claudia's
former instagram account girl with a
secret where people just anonymously
submitted some of their deepest darker
secrets it's completely anonymous we
don't even know who they're from and 100
anonymous
100 percent
that was good
um
and people just really unburdened
themselves we shared the secrets we
absorbed them we reacted to them we
tried not to give advice because it
wasn't like you were looking for advice
these are secrets and we tried not to
judge from like 15 years ago but it was
just like
so entertaining people loved the episode
we're definitely gonna do a part two
because we still have so many more
secrets and they're still coming in and
jackie literally when i opened up my
computer today to record the podcast the
last thing we had done was the patreon
the google form is up on my computer
there was over a hundred new entries oh
my god okay so we're definitely going to
do more it's a great time to become a
patreon member patreon.com the morning
toast that episode was really
really fun to record and also i thought
you were gonna say this but i do need to
clarify something from yesterday's
episode yes you do okay with harry and
megan
so much stuff first of all
i had said i misspoke yesterday because
i misunderstood they were offering to
pay for their security in the uk the
problem is so it has to do with like gun
laws in the uk and who can be armed and
pretty much like only the highest
highest level most police officers
aren't even armed it's not like it is
here so they wanted to pay for armed
police protection and the government
said this isn't a service that you can
just pay for no one can you can they
were offering to pay they were offering
to pay but like these police officers
aren't for hire you know it's like
trying to get like by police protection
that you that's just not something that
you can do even though that's what they
wanted to do i was but in america you
can have like armed security guards
right right and also so they
could bring their own security from
america but then those american security
agents aren't going to get access to the
uk intelligence and work with the police
in the uk because it's like a foreign
foreign body and they're not going to
share intel with them so it's a lot more
complex than like even you know like
page six is is citing and it's i think
it's really confusing especially for
americans because we're like why can't
you have our own security like every
celebrity here has armed security so i
was actually reading these instagram
stories by uh this uh
account called the royal watcher she has
a highlight called security and it's all
about this and and what's actually going
on i found it to be really interesting
but i just wanted to clear up they were
willing to pay they weren't expecting
taxpayers to pay for it but it's just
not something that you can pay for these
aren't for hire they're you know
government officials right but we did
like totally misrepresent the story by
accident and it happens to the best of
us like we cannot be everything to
everyone all the time it was an accident
i take full responsibility but then so
we
we got it wrong and then i was reading
what other people were sending me and
then i read even more and i realized
what the news articles are saying are
also misrepresenting the situation so
there's there's just like so much more
to this story and it just has to do with
like
what we expect here versus what goes on
over there it's a cultural difference
it's a cultural difference like i think
a lot of these things are
when we all talk about like when america
voices
people in the uk just like talk about
the royals and like what's expected we
don't even have [ __ ] royals like who
are we to say no and like we're more
obsessed with the royals in america than
the people in like britain are yeah and
we're no i'm telling you we are who me
and you or this country us oh we're so
obsessed and we know nothing and yeah no
but they're so obsessed over there too
and as americans like we just don't
we all don't understand a lot the
nuances yeah so
just i need to clear that up we just are
a bunch of monarchists
we're royalists
sure
because like it's a not like yes they
have a monarch over there but it's not
like their countries it's
they're not like ruled but they're not
like ruled by the queen she doesn't have
that much she has no power yeah
she's just a queen literally
are you ready for our next story
now i do feel ready i wasn't ready
before
adele tears up while announcing her las
vegas residency is being postponed this
was really crazy
adele posted a video last night
profusely apologizing for postponing her
weekends with adele residency at
caesar's palace in las vegas which was
scheduled to begin today
so she took to twitter and said hi
listen i'm so sorry but my show ain't
ready we've tried absolutely everything
that we can to put it together in time
and for it to be good enough for you but
we've been absolutely destroyed by
delivery delays and covid half my crew
half my team is down with kobit they
still are and it's been impossible to
finish the show i can't give you what i
have right now and i'm gutted i'm gutted
and i'm sorry it's so last minute
so the show was supposed to tell you
people i heard oh obviously already
bought their tickets to get there people
were on the plane people are in the
hotel rooms yeah and it's cancelled
so i heard two things okay the first
thing i heard is that she
saw that 100 was coming out and felt
extremely threatened and just didn't she
could feel like the new era of my music
kind of taking over the music industry
and she just didn't want to compete
against that because like you know she's
she's tired you know she's been through
a lot and she's just not in the mood to
put up another fight with an iconic pop
star and that was kind of the reason
behind like the catalyst that got her to
um
to cancel the shows that's what i heard
and what was the second thing that you
heard well the second thing i read on
dumas was that like
yes what adele said is true like there
have been delays because of covet and
people are getting coveted
but it was like a creative thing like
she's worked like worked on the show
like if she wanted if if she wanted to
put together a show and perform tonight
like she could have it wasn't like there
wasn't one dancer in las vegas who
couldn't make it it was possible she
just like wasn't super happy with it and
like i get i get wanting perfection for
yourself 100 but like it seems and don't
come for me like it seems incredibly
selfish
when like the first row of your show was
going for forty thousand dollars a seat
like that's what it was and i was
actually talking to two people who work
in las vegas in the entertainment
industry and they were like and they're
like high up they're like we cannot get
tickets like when i tell you like every
seat no one paid less than a thousand
dollars for the worst seat in the house
like and these are adele's like
tried and true fans and honestly it was
just like i think she could have handled
it way better well of course
everything's being postponed i'm s there
are refunds but that is so you can't get
a refund for your airplane no you can't
you can't get a refund for your time and
you know your pto the nanny yeah the pto
but here's the thing i feel so many ways
about this one like i i know
that adele feels all of these things and
evaluated all of those things before she
made her decision
but it's hard not to think and i know
i'm sim being simplistic and there's so
much more that goes into it but like
adele is one of the few singers who
could just get up there with a
microphone
an instrumental version of her song at
and give us a show an amazing show like
it's not as if she's someone who needs
all of these sets and all this
production what she needs is musicians
but you know there are musicians out
there and even if the first show wasn't
going to be creatively what she wanted
which i understand that it wasn't going
to happen whether say like 25 of the
musicians are out we saw that special on
oprah like she has a full orchestra band
like
that's a lot of people that need to stay
healthy and be able to perform with you
but i feel like
and obviously she weighed all of these
things before she made this decision i
don't think anybody is feeling this
burden more than her
but it could have been done it wouldn't
have been the a-plus thing that she
wanted but
would it have been better to show is her
voice would it have been better to do
like a b-minus show she's incapable of
putting on a b minor show like for real
and you know what you know katy perry
launched her
vegas residency two weeks ago and i've
seen videos of it she has the crazy
because it's so katy craziest lights
craziest dancers craziest costume she
has an enormous toilet like it's above
and beyond it's [ __ ] crazy and
everyone's like it's camp but it's crazy
okay so if she's able to do that in
covet times in las vegas like i do think
they could have gotten themselves a very
good show and i just think if she wanted
to have canceled it because it wasn't
working out creatively
the last possible time she could have
done that was a week ago
yeah
and but i'm sure a week ago she was like
no we're going to figure it out and
we're going to do this and i'm adele and
i can sing and something made it so that
like they actually can't do it
and
i'm i it just feels like silly to even
be like but you could have tried it
could have been okay because i'm sure
she tried everything
it's just really crazy that like there
how bad could it have been
right for her to have cancelled it's
just
uh the part that like bothered me when i
heard it was like i was seeing people on
tik tok like literally getting the
twitter notification from adele like as
they're in the cab from the airport you
know like people got it on the plane
it's just it's not fair to play like
people spend their hard-earned money on
shows and and these artists mean like if
you're going to spend a lot of money on
an artist like it's because that artist
means a lot to you like their music
means a lot to you and i know she knows
all of this and i'm not saying i'm mad
at adele but like this is a situation
that can and should have been handled
very differently but you don't think she
like she feels all of those things so
that's why i'm just like she knows all
of this and she also knows that like she
can do a show like she could just get up
there
and do anything
yeah
so i think this decision clearly weighed
very heavily on her she's very emotional
in the video
and
i'm just
i would have i need to understand even
more like how many people were you were
you supposed to have on stage with you
how many are out with kovid what didn't
show up like because i just don't i feel
like she still could have done it but
she obviously couldn't because she can't
because she's not agreed agreed to
everything you just said yeah
so anyone who's in las vegas for adele
um there's a lot of katy perry there's
fun stuff to do there you know have a
great time for those of us who aren't
there because it's just there are worse
places to be like stranded it's the
greatest city in the world i think
people are like it's one word paris
london
las vegas
because you know what you got paris and
vegas you got new york and vegas you got
it all
no it's a multicultural
bustling metropolis of
city life
it's amazing it's an amazing place and
oh my gosh same speaking of amazing our
next story just warms the cockles of my
heart are you ready
is it the story that warms the cockle of
your hearts that's brought to you by
legacy box perchance cause legacy box
also warms the cockles of my heart yes
exactly so what's your new year's
resolution if you're like most there's a
box of your family's treasured home
movies and photos tucked inside a closet
that you've been meaning to preserve but
you weren't sure where to start legacy
box makes checking this off your to-do
list super easy simply send your legacy
box filled with old home movies and
photos and you'll get back digital
copies that can be easily enjoyed shared
and organized it's like magic so this is
something i think every single person
who grew up in the 90s or 80s or early
2000s can relate to like these boxes of
videos that you're just dying to see but
how the hell do you get a cassette tape
to play on your phone well here's how
legacy boxes team of 200 trained
technicians will process 19 for 19
different media types from a vhs to a
super 8 film by hand and they'll do it
right here in the usa
it's so easy you sign up for legacy box
they'll send you the box put all your
crap in it send it to them and you'll
get back a digitized copy and the
original copies of all your home movies
and photos so you can get it on a thumb
drive the cloud it's so easy and they
update you along the way so you know all
of your family's memories are being
preserved safely they have an online
tracking system so you get up to 12
emails updated along the process so you
always know where you're at each
purchase includes access to a special
concierge available seven days a week to
answer all of your legacy box questions
so kick off the new year by rescuing
your family's most cherished memories go
to legacybox.com toast to take advantage
of an exclusive discount for for you
guys that's legacy box legacy
box dot com slash toast
seriously just do it already and you
know what your grandma your mom like
it's the best gift you can give them
they will literally sob if you want to
be the favorite child or grandchild
you're welcome
you're welcome okay our story
is luke combs and his wife nicole are
expecting their first baby together they
say this may be the best year yet so
both luke and nicole shared the exciting
news in an instagram post last night
captioning the sweet collection of snaps
of them in their sonogram saying here we
go y'all little do lil dude combs is
coming this spring couldn't be more
excited to start a family with this babe
it's gonna be a hell of a ride
okay first of all
those photos they took on the beach i've
never seen like besides for you
obviously
like pregnancy
pregnancy glow like she looked so
different like so
angelic and like it was like honestly
perhaps aside from yours
the most like
glowing announcement like it was just
really shocking she looked like a like
she was born for this like she looked
amazing
and i can't help but think like
we're gonna get like
isn't she lovely by stevie wonder level
type of music about
childbirth about motherhood about being
a dad like i cannot wait no i'm so
excited um my pregnancy announcement
photos were taken on self timer in my
living room so it's totally
fine it's totally like a tripod
so it's fine you never know
oh thank you no these photos were so
stunning i just i was
it's so crazy like so it's so funny like
which announcements like just really
like hit homemate and maybe it's because
i'm like eight and a half months
pregnant and i just like love luca nico
so much it's just like really
it made me like emotional i'm so excited
not just you it's not just you and it's
like i really feel so blessed to you
know with my fellow like pregnancy
pregnant ladies right now like
especially the people that i follow and
what's also crazy is so many of the
people that like i'm pregnant with in
the last six months um have given birth
already so yeah now gates right raven
like chelsea curtis emily donato like
everyone's sort of cycling out and so to
have nico like on the rest of this
journey with me like i really i'm
feeling really good like it's me nico
kylie morgan stewart
what a crew so we saw nico like a month
ago
you know
me and margo and she like wasn't
drinking but you know me i was like not
even noticing because like i was so
drunk and then when she posted her
announcement margo obviously texted me
within five seconds of it going up and
was like this is why nico wasn't
drinking and i'm like oh like it all
made sense i didn't even realize you saw
her
yeah
pregnant
and you didn't even know didn't even
know and then when i texted her i was
like oh my god congrats she was like it
was so hard not to drink with you guys
like queen oh my god that is so cute i'm
so happy for them like it's just it's
beautiful the miracle of life you know
and it's like they're just so
perfect like i can't like i've never in
my life felt so connected to an
instagram post that like had nothing to
do with me you know
i feel similarly you know i'm like i'm
like how do i make this about me like
this is me this is my life like get me
in that photo like what i would have
done to been like
the photographer yeah yeah so special it
was really special and i was just like
really feeling um the emotions and i'm
so happy for them like truly truly true
talk about like just two people who
deserve happiness and they're getting it
with their little baby i think they said
it was a boy right yeah a boy which like
i love the gender of an outright gender
reveal me too like no drama just gender
no drama just gender like information
at our fingertips
so i can't wait to see the pregnancy
content like it's just gonna be too good
the songs the instagrams like we're
about to go on the best nine months of
our lives yeah well i think it's like
they said spring 2022 so i think it's
probably like six more months
amazing
okay are you ready for our next story
no i just want to like literally keep
talking about these two i know and these
are the next story is too that you don't
want to keep talking about because is it
britney and jamie it's brittany and
jamie lynn part two of caller daddy came
out last night so it was like the second
half of the interview that they filmed
over a week ago and then there was also
a follow-up zoom because of all the news
that made news in the time since they
filmed wow good for alex like not
letting the podcast go stale yes okay so
honestly i don't know if it's me or if
it was the episode but like i barely
absorbed anything because jamie lynn has
officially fatigued me
on this story so she talks about the
ways that she tried to like free herself
from the britney conservatorship
over the last free sorry free britney
from the conservative ship over the last
13 years she cites like a time that they
were in hawaii and britney was confiding
in her and jamie lynn told her to like
move out of california for six months
and then the conservatorship would be
dissolved which just seems like a really
simplistic like oh that's the solution
she could have done that the whole time
right so it was just a lot of stuff like
that how jamie lynn like spoke up to
lawyers and then like jamie lynn got in
trouble
and
um but it was jamie's
it was all like so vague
and then she provides like all of these
text messages which even though she's
reading like i just couldn't absorb or
like
i don't know what they said i watched
the whole thing i don't know what they
said i don't know what she said but this
has been a brilliant pr move because i
no longer
care care
no i actually think this has been a
brilliant pr move on jamie lynn's behalf
because
i think obviously the goal of this these
interview series and this book which no
one was going to give the book the time
of day but i think a lot of people are
like turning for jamie like
from the podcast or at least
understanding her personally i am not
like
here like for the most part you either
believe jamie or stan with brittany like
you really can't do both and i just
stand with brittany and like so that's
why that's why i've been fatigued by
this story like even if jamie is telling
the truth and every like i don't care
like i stayed with brittany yeah i mean
it definitely it couldn't doing these
episodes i don't think hurt her at all
because any time like you hear someone's
story you hear like the frog in their
throat as they're talking about like
getting dms
and you know being scared and all these
things like it it just humanizes a
person and you do realize like the whole
world it's like a grade it's been this
free britney movement for so long and
now all of a sudden that means like we
have to drag jamie lynn through the
streets like
why can't we free britney and also just
go back to like however we felt about
jamie lynn before that you know like
there's so many more like nefarious
actors in the free brittany like yes
world you know um obviously her parents
and
lou lou taylor right and so i just i
really feel like this is
and i felt this way from the first
episode it's like jamie lynn
is kind of like irrelevant to the story
like
and now somehow she's become like the
face of the villain right but i just
feel like when it all started like she's
just not germane to the way that it all
unfolded i don't think anything she
could have done along the way might have
helped people she was vehement that she
has not benefited or participated in the
conservatorship at all
she said because remember how we had
said and we had read that like she was
getting paid from
she was like another person on the
payroll of the conservatorship she said
like her name is in those documents many
times she said she has nothing to do
with the conservatorship the only time
her name is in the documents is because
at one point britney asked her to be a
trustee on a trust for britney's boys
the kids if anything were to happen to
britney and jamie lynn like said that
she would but then and so because
britney like that that was going to
happen that had to be
uh shown to the court anytime britney
makes any sort of moves or decision or
does anything it all goes into the court
so the court had on file that jamie lynn
is going to be a trustee on this account
then jamie lynn didn't like ever do the
bare minimum of becoming a trustee she
said she just like didn't want to do it
which i thought was interesting like why
not kind of [ __ ] up yeah and so then
and then the court documents say that
jamie lynn is not a trustee because she
didn't do what she needed to do so she
says that's the only time her name
appears in these things and it has to do
with a trust that has nothing to do with
the conservatorship
just the kids
just like an aside anybody could any
human being could set up a trust for
their kids and then say hey can you be a
trustee
got it okay it's not like she was a
trustee on the conservatorship which i
think people like had read it that way
but
again i don't [ __ ] know
no and this is the thing like everyone's
just saying conflicting things and
there's legal documents that support
what everyone says and like i just don't
i'm just fatigued like i just want
britney to have peace and i just think
that the concept of her sister writing
this book
when like
the whole concept of her book and i've
said this earlier in the week is like
you know my life was never about me i
was always living in the sister the
shadow of my sister
and i went through this you know teenage
pregnancy and like it was still always
about brittany bernie bernie and then
it's like she writes this book and the
timing is so bad because the book even
though it mentions brittany quite a bit
is not really supposed to be about
brittany it's supposed to be about like
jamie but even now it's like the book is
about britney the press is about britney
and i don't know if that she's doing
that intentionally or that's just
because your sister is the biggest pop
star in the world and is currently going
through one of the biggest national news
stories of all time but it's like enough
like just let brittany have the moment
yeah like let brittany find peace and in
this second part especially when they
got on zoom and jamie lynn was like
sharing text messages between
her and brittany like
that were meant to exonerate her but i
have to be honest like i just
i don't know if i have pregnancy brain i
i couldn't even tell you what they said
it was like a lot of word salads you
know i think that there's a special
place no i don't want to say that
actually i just really do not like when
people share private messages publicly
yeah especially with your family members
family like that's like just disgraceful
in my opinion
so i just think as a society like the
discourse we're having around jamie lynn
like we can keep it healthy but so many
people are coming for her looks and
that's just [ __ ] mean and i don't
think we should do that like oh where's
nothing to do with it where do you see
stuff like that all over tik tok twitter
people just like making comments it's
like leave her alone okay like that's
not what this is about
yeah that's unnecessary i am i'm glad to
say that i don't even like see stuff
like that
i only see what like the toast after
dark thinks about things that's my
twitter same and they're brutal
okay well i really hope we can put the
story to bed and barring anything
actually consequential happening no more
back and forth instagram captions like
it's a little china for the time being
i agree even then that's not two because
i got up some flack earlier in the week
for being like i'm over these two that
doesn't mean i don't want britney to
have her freedom and her happiness i'm
just personally like fatigued by sisters
fighting and like like instagram notes
apps back and forth and things changing
every single day and like one day
calling someone scum and the other
saying like i love you you're my sister
like i just i i don't have the energy
like it's whiplash
i have a hobby for you jackie have you
heard of wordle
people were suggesting it
but i don't know what it is okay so i
start it was my first day it was my
first day yesterday it's like a it's a
website you go to on your phone just
like google wordle okay and it's a
puzzle that comes out every single day
everyone has gets the same puzzle and
you have to figure out it's like a word
jumble you're very smart and like good
with words i think you'll like it it's
actually it's very challenging like i
did my first one yesterday and i got it
right but it took me like 15 minutes
like it's not just like a game you play
it takes time to like sit and think it
through i i can't really explain the
rules but when you open the website like
they'll just explain it to you there's
just a five letter word that you have to
guess but they give you no clues
that's pretty cool and then what happens
if you like wait is it like hq where
you're competing with like on the
leaderboard or it's just for personal
enjoyment
that's an interesting call i'm sure
they're i mean i'm not involved with the
leaderboard because i just got involved
yesterday and i did mine today and like
i'm actually kind of good at it i also i
heard about what you did
i know don't bring it up okay i got
literally canceled on the internet
yesterday like right before my song came
out and like i didn't need that type of
bad press all press is good press when
you have a song coming out
so i didn't realize that like
one wordle comes out every day and
everyone gets the same word so at 7 p.m
i was like i did it i got it on the
fourth try and you only get like six
so i screenshot it i was like yes i got
the word
and people and i left my phone i think i
went to like walk theo like i left my
phone for longer than usual because you
know i'm on my phone every minute yeah
but i think i maybe like made like a
snack or something
i come back my phone is being lit up
like you spoiled it and i'm like what
everyone gets the same word that's so
stupid i didn't know that so oh my god
there's like a special way to share your
score i learned it all now
but oh my god people are [ __ ] brutal
the wordle community is cut throat damn
well now you know
and now you know if you start playing
i'll check it out when listening doesn't
know what wordle is yeah i will check it
out but are you ready oh no you're not
ready have you heard of west elm caleb
i've heard those three words together
i've heard i
i've heard a little bit but i don't know
anything it's just a guy who was was
like dating all the girls in new york
city
i have like an extremely hot take on it
can you tell us what it is first for
those of us who are grannies so a couple
girls on tick tock like put together
that they all in the last couple years
or even like the last year
had had similar interactions on this
dating app with a guy named caleb who
works at west elm and he's basically
just a [ __ ] boy like he'll you know he
he he'll see multiple people at the same
time he's not committing any crimes i
don't think but he's just like an ass
like a classic douchebag fuckboy like so
what he's on a dating app and he goes on
a lot of dates he goes on a lot of dates
dates multiple women at the same time i
think he says a lot of the same things
to the women like douchebag just classic
douchebag behavior
okay
but it like became this big thing
because everyone put together on tick
tock that like they were all talking to
the same guy
and they the only things they really
knew about him was that his name was
caleb and he worked at west elm so now
he's been going around the internet as
west alm caleb and it's become this
enormous enormous story like he is
getting
annihilated like he had to delete his
linkedin
people are flooding the west elm
instagram being like [ __ ] caleb weston
km sucks
and everyone's like living for it and
like i get it it's fun to like hop on a
trend
and talk about and like be viral but but
the way that i understand and perhaps
i'm missing some information
the man has not committed any crimes
like being an [ __ ] is not a crime no
but but from what you're describing i
don't i still don't understand how he's
an [ __ ] like how many people are on
dating apps the point of dating apps is
to go on dates there are only so many
words in the english language like if
you like anyone who's like on a dating
app you say like the same like pick up
like hey you like [ __ ] like that like
to this to all the people that you're
trying to go out with like unless it's a
unless someone could give me a number
that would be like extreme like a serial
dater i that's what a dating app is
right hopefully if things go well like
you talk to people and you go on many
dates so 100 and so everyone's a kind of
coming on this train like west i'm caleb
like all these brands are like making
jokes on their brand social media like
ruggable you know the company that makes
those washable rugs
they're like well none of these rugs
from ruggable were designed by west elm
caleb so it's like this man who's like a
private citizen and whose only crime is
like being you know a [ __ ] boy which is
not a crime
is getting like his life ruined like
doxxed and like to me and everyone's
like it's like all fun and games and i'm
like what's wrong with everyone like
this is bad like this is not what the
internet is supposed to do it's just
like in my opinion and i think that this
is an extremely hot tape because most
people are having a lot of fun ganging
up on this man i think it's like the
worst
thing like you could do this is a
private citizen he wasn't posting on
tick tock he was on a private dating app
and they all just like put it together
and used his pictures and talked about
where he worked like is he getting fired
yeah that doesn't sit right with me but
i don't know the details of
this nefarious behavior of his beyond
going on a lot of dates and just like
as far as i know it's nothing nefarious
like
criminal it's just like being a dick
he's mean to the girls
no like um
not mean but not nice like classic man
behavior like
rude like manly bad at dating like bad
okay send me more stuff
i will
but still and also let us know what you
think like i might be missing some
information because i'm
going you know 27 going on 28 but i'm
pretty sure i have like a good grip on
the situation i feel like you would have
a good grip on the situation you're very
much kept abreast there's nothing that
happens on tick tock that you don't see
amen 100
100
for our fifth and final story we are
completely switching gears like 180
degrees from west elm caleb to little
titanic news that i found really
interesting
and now you're all gonna have to hear it
so
i don't know if you know this but you
love a titanic update i love a titanic
update it's been over a hundred years
and like there's still updates which is
just incredible there's a new book
coming out about the titanic and i don't
know if you know this about the titanic
but the night that the titanic
sank
there was a boat
nearby ish
who it like the titanic hit the iceberg
at 11 30 pm i just don't feel like
you're like paying attention to this
important
i was actually just looking up west i'm
caleb because i didn't want to misspeak
and i'm reading this buzzfeed article
which is a highly unreliable source
because they've written lies about many
people but what they said it turns out
that several women had similar
experience with the west elm furniture
designer he had ghosted them after a few
dates or texts and did some classic
fuckboy moves that's it
okay yeah no everyone's insane
the knights the titanic sank
there was a ship
not far away called the ss californian
but the titanic at the iceberg at 11 30
pm and the captain of the other boat
turned off his radar
and and went to sleep and missed all of
the distress signals from the titanic
and for a very long time like this
captain this man like it was it has been
said that like if he you know left it on
or had someone manning the channels that
they would have heard these calls they
would have went over to titanic and they
could have saved people who were
drowning who were freezing helped people
it helped people and etc
now there is a new book saying that the
sailor on the nearby ship who does
through the titanic distress calls did
not cost any lives the new historian is
overturning history's damning 110 year
old verdict
so only this man was alive to like be
exonerated to have his name cleared when
i read this book about the titanic um
imagine there were a lot of people who
lived with titanic guilt um anyone any
man who survived the titanic
like was shamed for really like the rest
of their lives because it was like meant
for like women and children to get in
those boats and if any women and
children died then and a man lived it
was like why were you on in that spot
and it's and it's like if they got went
yeah if they went from the titanic
straight into a lifeboat like oh my god
cancelled
if they went down with this
if they went down with the ship they got
in the water and then were pulled into a
lifeboat
hero
but there was like one captain of the
titanic not like he wasn't the main guy
but he was pretty high up who survived
and like for the rest of his life he was
just like
you know in this cloud of shame that you
know he should have gone down with the
[ __ ]
which is just how we'll go down with
this ship
so there's a lot of titanic shaming
going on um but cyril evans who manned
the telegraph equipment on the uss
californian apparently could not have
saved any victims of the sinking expert
analysis has concluded
uh they have decided that if even if
they had heard it and they went over it
still would have been too long people
would have already froze to death and
drown and it wouldn't have made any
difference
okay i mean a little too late cyril but
i don't i don't know
i that man must have lived like the
worst life ever after the titanic like
the guilt the shame from everyone like
he just wants to go to sleep yeah and
i'm pretty sure that after this like
then it became like maritime law that
you couldn't turn off
your there should always be someone
alerting like monitoring in the high
seas at all times
yeah but at the time it was it was
pretty common to to turn off to go to
bed like that wasn't crazy but
apparently like their ship was also
surrounded by ice it would have taken
them so long to navigate through all of
it and get over to the titanic and it
probably wouldn't have made any
difference
so you know what's something i struggle
with what
remembering that the titanic was an
actual event that happened because to me
it's just the movie you know and then it
makes it like so much more sadder when
you realize and for me watching um
downton abbey when like the first season
is like about the titanic because they
spoiler alert
it's in the first cousin it's in the
first half the first episode um
i'm like oh my god yeah this was like a
real a historical event not just an
oscar-winning film yeah no the book that
i read about it called the ship of
dreams which really um
i felt covered it from soup to nuts
because at the end like it was a very
you know finite amount of time it talks
about like all the different people
working on it you know all
the food that they ate every night
leading up to it like the menu like all
of this stuff like so it really was a
one-stop shop for titanic information
and also a lot of the people who um
died and like what what they were about
and who they were and how it sort of
like changed the course of
history and such because there was you
know some people that
you would you would recognize their
names now
right right
wow okay that actually is super
interesting i got to get more into the
titanic i would rec if you have any
titanic curiosity scratch the itch uh
with the ship of dreams you will feel
say after that i was like i've got it
i'm good the thing is i'm reading the
hating game right now the the book
that's being turned in into a movie with
lucy hale yeah and i just don't think i
can really do both like not one after
the other i'm not that girl you know
what i've heard recently from um like
the redheads facebook group what people
are doing is they'll read
like two books at the same time one like
totally like fiction hating game like
boy beats girl and one completely
different like a non-fiction ship of
dreams and you'll never get the two
confused
that's actually true because the fact
that i read like all the same types of
books i never know like if you tell me a
book that i've read i'll be like which
one's up yeah you could about the girl
is it about the girl who finds out her
dad is actually her her mom or is it
about the girl who jumps off the yacht
you couldn't read like colleen hoover
and christina lauren at the same time
right
they're literally the same right but if
you did have like if you had one
non-fiction book going and one fiction
book going i actually think that's a
pretty
cool idea because sometimes you're in
the mood for something different
yeah
so think about it
um
is that was that the fifth that was the
fifth and final story i feel as though
you needed to know it i guess justice
for cyril evans hopefully his family can
have some peace um
but still titanic
rest in peace
rest abuse um well let's dive into the
tv recap because i have a lot of things
i want to talk to you about and that tv
recap segment is brought to you by
betterhelp so today's episode is
sponsored by betterhelp online therapy
we talk about betterhelp a lot on the
show and this month we're discussing
some of the stigmas around mental health
for example some people think you should
wait until things are unbearable to go
to therapy but that's totally untrue
therapy is a tool to utilize before
things get worse and it can also help
you avoid those lows a lot of people
also think therapy is for so-called
crazy people but therapy doesn't mean
something's wrong with you it means you
recognize that all humans have emotions
and we all need to learn to control them
and not avoid them so better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to because like that could be awkward
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online
the podcast
the morning toast obviously has a
great offer for you guys so you can get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com toast that's betterhelp
e-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash toast
um okay tv recap the first thing i want
to talk about is with you is ted lasso
because i did start it to be honest i
had no idea what it was about and then
when you were just basically telling me
it's like this feel good disney channel
show
i was like you know what i could use
that
and from the minute i started watching
it like i totally understood the appeal
it really is like nothing bad happens
like it's just really sweet and
sometimes i hate shows where like the
protagonist is like so happy and kind
that they're like stupid
yeah you know yeah
but ted is not stupid he's actually
extremely clever and club but he is very
kind and southern and sometimes i feel
like they equate that with being stupid
no he's you could be smart and nice yeah
no he is very um he's just optimistic
and also as you get deeper into the show
you'll realize that he definitely has
some demons you know no one is just like
so one-dimensional like that
so yeah there's more to ted than meets
the eye but i agree it's like he he just
answers every question with positivity
but it's not stupidity
right and some of the [ __ ] he says is
incredibly powerful like he said two
thing i watched only four episodes and
there were two things that really stuck
with me what's the happiest um
animal on earth a goldfish because he
has a 10 second memory like oh my god
genius the other thing he said they say
youth is wasted on the young
and then he was like don't waste your
wisdom on your
something hold on i want to say it
because it was actually really ted lasso
youth
wasted on the young
i was like shook by it oh here
you know how they say that youth is
wasted on the young well i say don't let
the wisdom of age be wasted on you
stunning stunning
um and the other thing i like about the
show is like there's so many good
characters like obviously ted but nate
the um i don't know what he is like the
man like the locker room he's like the
water boy
oh my god i literally die for him and
like when ted bought him a suit for the
benefit i was like gonna cry this is so
cute like he's such a great like extra
character um and i just love the show
and like now what's annoying is that i
started with ben so like i will be
finishing it in a month because ben no
you have to lately you have to finish it
by monday i'm sorry
that's what i told ben yeah no tell him
like he it's the weekend it's a very
short show and we're gonna need your
opinions by monday because um like
things weirdly
there's twists and turns
well i'm trying to see like is ted i
know he has like this woman back home
but like we don't know anything about
her and it's like is he gonna get on
with the team owner or maybe that guy's
ex-girlfriend who like seems to take an
interest in ted keelie
keeley oh my god and like ted is just so
cute like he comes into the restaurant
and the guy's like who are you and he's
like oh i wrote in your taxi today you
told me that your family has a great
indian restaurant oh my god it was just
i like it's really like a show this is
so me like everyone's like watched ted
lasso for literally two years i'm like
no now i'm like gagging over it so good
i'm so glad that you gave it a chance
that you're liking it i was actually
thinking you were going to come on here
because the way that you were just
talking about it like i watched ted last
one have things to say
i don't know i thought i thought maybe
you're gonna be like this [ __ ] is so
dumb but i'm i had all the same feelings
as you and sugar you just absolutely
need to finish it by monday that's all
i'll say because i promise i just it's
it's an emotional
it's an emotional journey and
rollercoaster and it's just it's a
beautiful show and it because it gets
sad
i never felt sad okay
i never but everyone but the characters
like it's nice because it's you know a
very nice pleasant show but the
characters aren't so one-dimensional
like you get to know them all better
everyone has a story
oh and like in the first episode was
sprat from downton abbey and i was
quaking right spratt and then later
you'll see lady shackleton
i was looking for her but i didn't see
her yet yeah um sprout is actually great
in it
yeah he is he's very funny and he that
makes up for him being sprat
and the writing is just really clever
like so many funny jokes just really
good yeah really really good and i like
the soccer element too
me too i don't know much about football
but it's exciting it is exciting so okay
i'm so glad that you
you are on this journey
um and then i want to talk to you about
sex in the city oh and just like that
and just like that so i watched the most
recent two episodes and i've i really do
like the show i just want to say like i
do like it but i'm gonna be extremely
critical of it
because in a lot of ways
we know these women like before the show
like we know them really well and so
it's hard for me to believe that some of
them have turned into the women that
they are now it's just like not
believable for me i think the most
accurate
i actually think carrie and charlotte
are both
perfectly representing how i think they
would turn out like carrie has not
changed at all like she's exactly who
she was unfortunately and i believe
that's unfortunately but i do believe
that's how she would have grown up right
charlotte
is literally like a karen like she was
like learning about like new age
feminism and like carrie you're
mansplaining me like it's just so cringy
she's like using these words that she's
obviously read like from the new york
times and like trying to apply it to her
daily life and it's just like so moronic
and i actually can see that's how she
turned out because she was like very
buttoned up and then like her friends
brought out like her wild side and her
more like i just i could see that
happening for her
what i don't see happening is that this
is what miranda evolved into and i'm not
talking about her sexuality i'm just
talking about like her as a person like
she's kind of reckless and nuts when
always she was like extremely type a
organized and people like that like do
not change like if you're type a you are
always typed out if you're organized
you're always organized like that's who
you are
in what sense though like
would you say that she was type a and
what's and how is she behaving now
well that was like her whole thing like
in the original show she's like
extremely cynical very realistic like
got her job went to law school yale
harvard bought her own apartment like
she was always the one just like on
track with like the things that she
thought were important career apartment
boyfriend baby you know like she did it
yeah i would have said that like
charlotte was more type a than um
miranda like i don't i think that like
miranda was very driven ambitious and
hard-working but like in her like you
know when we would see her in her like
home scene she was always just like
eating takeout over the sink
that's true but i think like during the
original show like charlotte
to start versus charlotte at the end
like she had character growth like she
wasn't that like crazy buttoned up like
yes she was still very park avenue but
she was like embracing new
yeah
yeah exactly because miranda was still
the same stubborn [ __ ] she always was
that's why we loved her yeah but also
because like life threw charlotte some
curveballs and she had to adjust
also through miranda curveballs
okay
so i'm just having a hard time like
understanding like that this is what uh
miranda grew up into
but beyond that another character who's
like somehow
i'm just not not who i thought he was
gonna be when he grew up is steve he's
like this
like idiot like
they treat him like he's like brain dead
he's just deaf like he's partially deaf
in one ear and they act like he can't do
anything and that he's senile like
because he likes to watch tv like it's
just like the steve that we knew was
like such a go-getter hustler like for
miranda for brady a family man like
this is not not it
what that's not the steve i know
what do you mean he was just like
extremely like simple
no he was always like a better husband
opening his own bar
i don't know
like from the you have to think about
the character girl i guess when we met
him he was like uh a bartender with like
not a lot of ambition and just kind of
like stagnant in his life and miranda
definitely brought out and by the time
they actually got together he was like a
business owner like he was hustling yes
hustle but that i don't that's not how i
see him hustling for miranda you telling
me that he's spending his time on the
couch watching tv like tracks
okay maybe not the tv thing but just
like complacent in his relationship with
miranda like who doesn't even want to
have sex with her anymore like that's
not
they're still trying to turn out in my
opinion well so i'm so glad you asked
spoiler alert turn off if the episode's
over after this so if you haven't
watched go
miranda is in love with che you did i
tell you about chai yes or if you
haven't then i've seen it like on
headlines and stuff yeah
so they're like having a relationship
and che believes that it's because
miranda's in an open marriage and then
miranda's like no like i'm not and chase
like i'm not like doing this with you
like i'm not gonna be like some secret
so miranda had to really weigh like
what am i gonna do and miranda's like
their time is moving very fast
miranda is in love with che so she tells
steve she wants a divorce she's met
someone else he says i want you to be
happy it's actually really like lovely
and she's so excited
and so she's on the phone with carrie
and she's like i'm heading to the
airport carrie's like why she will chase
in cleveland and i told her i was going
to leave steve and i did it and i want
to go surprise her and then the episode
ends so obviously she goes to cleveland
and che is like [ __ ] some girl in in
her dressing room that's obviously what
happened so
then it's like where does miranda go
from here you know
um and then with carrie i actually like
what they did with carrie because they
they let a few months roll by so we
didn't have to like see her in her like
deep grief
and she wrote a book
like loved and lost her uh
publishers loved it like she's getting
back to work being a writer like back to
her og stuff she's back to living in her
brownstone but there's like this cool
young jewelry designer who lives beneath
her and like carrie wants to be like her
friend it's it's actually getting it's
getting much better like
the show at first was i think just
extremely shocking especially in the way
that they
um
talk about their age like they talk
about their age like they're 95 when
they're 55.
have you and it's just frustrating have
you seen that like the age of the just
like that ladies they're the same age as
the golden girls
well yes but it just doesn't feel that
way no but i think it's also just uh
um
a sign of you know how our like we think
about
women of a certain age has changed in a
positive way yeah
yeah that's true because to me they're
all
have much life to live you know
yeah
so um
it's great they're really putting
emphasis on on some of the new
characters because of course like
stamford is gone and um
samantha
so seema who is um
carrie's
real estate agent who helped her sell
the apartment with big it was just like
this really cool rich chic indian woman
who's never been married and like she's
becoming a part of the crew she comes to
lunch sometimes and then there's ldw who
is another mom at charlotte's school
who's like this incredibly cool woman
her and her husband are just like elite
and all charlotte wants to do is be a
friend um and they're really connecting
and so she's obviously gonna become like
a road they have rotating fourths oh
that's cool and hopefully yeah it's
really not bad yeah okay i'm glad that
you're enjoying it
i've surprised myself by how much i look
forward to the episodes when at first i
was extremely critical but you know what
i just love the gals i do i love the
gals i'm sorry i'm saying it i like and
just like that
wow
i like it
good you should you're spending your
time watching it
i hope olivia austria listens to this
episode because like she watches every
episode and she's like turns it off
she's like this show sucks i'm like why
are you still watching it i know she
likes it too it's okay you guys we can
say we like it
okay you like it i'm glad that you do
you should only watch television that
you like that sparks joy otherwise it's
a complete waste of time
100
100
don't let them [ __ ] go hard till the
end cause you know that we are
all right my song is out you guys
spotify itunes apple music all the
places please stream it purchase it
support independent artist that's what i
am i'm an independent artist i would
really appreciate any purchases of the
song any streams of the song and just
like honestly enjoy it it's really the
gno anthem is what people are saying
it's like for girls night going on a
bachelorette party out to dinner it's a
perfect pregame song add it to your
playlists i hope you like it and if
you're coming to one of my shows
i suggest you learn it because it's
going to be an integral part of the show
and like you don't want to be left out
so the lyrics are online learn them
love you guys anything else you want to
say jackie before we wrap up for the
week no just
have a great weekend everyone we'll see
you on monday uh head over to
patreon.com if you want more content i
don't know if you're taking a road trip
or something um we're always here for
you
always
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast
the millennium morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we need
subscribers come on we're also available
as a podcast and where podcasts can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio ihop radio cast box all the
places so wherever you listen to podcast
find us the morning toast and leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing amazing day morning
show's instagram update we are still not
back we are still working on it and we
are still hopeful have a great day
everyone we'll see you on monday
you know what it's kind of nice
never
love you